politicians with a couple of exceptions
are [ __ ]
thieves
thugs and fools that's what politicians
are all of them with a couple of
exceptions that's why we have a
constitution
because the people who wrote the
constitution understood that
right that they were just regular guys
and right now regular guys and women
right and that maybe
they would abide by the rules
and because they weren't going to abide
by the rules every couple of years we
had to vote we had to kick them out
because they didn't abide by the rules
and
if they were caught cheating lying
whoring whatever
the newspapers would rat them out
right so newspapers don't do that
anymore the legacy newspapers
and if you look at the politicians who
weren't [ __ ]
thieves thugs and fools
what happened to all of them
they killed him
so how do we get out of this i mean it's
connected to what the purpose of the
book is the point of the book of this
this pivotal moment you know can we can
we save this great experiment uh but how
do we get out of this sort of culturally
politically
uh spiritually however you want to take
that
well you're doing it i'm trying to do
something
sure i mean what what what you know it's
like golden myers remember her secret
weapon
remember what it was
i should know this i should know this it
was the people it was
it was the people she said
no she said there's no alternative
israel is a secret weapon there's no
alternative
right so our our secret weapon is there
no alternative so is that going to mean
we're going to die at our post yeah
maybe
sure we're going to die anyway so the
question is how do we want to spend our
lives in the midst of this vast upheaval
so for years i thought it was a huge
mistake on the right for people to say
well if if we did this if the
republicans did this i can't believe
that
well it's time to believe it now
it's because it's true
that that we there's a moment in our
country that something new something new
has to emerge and we're either going to
emerge into a um all civilizations die
we're going to emerge accept the jews
which is why people hate us
we're going to emerge into a vigorous
maturity
or we're going to be taken over by
russia china and iran
there you go
i suspect you don't think that the
people in charge at the moment are quite
up to the task
well they aren't in charge they're along
for the ride you know there's a bunch of
um
politicians with a couple of exceptions
are [ __ ]
thieves
thugs and fools that's what politicians
are all of them with a couple of
exceptions that's why we have a
constitution
because the people who wrote the
constitution understood that
right that they were just regular guys
and right now regular guys and women
right and that maybe
they would abide by the rules
and because they weren't going to abide
by the rules every couple of years we
had to vote we had to kick them out
because they didn't abide by the rules
and
if they were caught cheating lying
whoring whatever
the newspapers would rat them out right
so newspapers don't do that anymore the
legacy newspapers
and if you look at the politicians who
weren't [ __ ]
thieves thugs and fools
what happened to all of them
they killed him
right
put pretty good examples my favorite jew
jesus killed him
churchill they threw him out of office
right saved western civilization they
shot dr king they shot lincoln they took
trump who only wanted to do a good job
and treated him worse than any other
citizen in this country has ever been
treated and they're still added so the
people who say wait a second no no no
do not look behind the curtain
or the left and so the right says
there's nobody there that was what my
book was like the secret knowledge isn't
any secret knowledge because what does
it cost
what
here
here's what politics is it's
the post office
the navy and the army and the marines
and the coast that's it
anything beyond that
you're going to attract the horse these
above on fools
so trump comes in and says yeah let's
deal with that let everything else go
ahead they want to kill him
because he's completely opposed to the
zeitgeist to to the spirit of the time
on the left
so they say oh my god he said this and
he said that about grabbing the girl
that's [ __ ] that's the same thing as
saying that jews you know they're greasy
you know
it's it's it's finding a reason for your
prejudice that seems to make sense to
you
i'll say oh okay you know he's got a big
mouth and he sticks his foot in it
therefore
i tell you what let's open our borders
and and to give all of our money right
about it start a nuclear war with iran
that seemed does that seem like a good
idea
so the people and the conservatives say
that's a rotten idea
let's stop it using the means at our
disposal
the problem is
[Music]
in any
cat fight
the person screaming the loudest is
probably in the wrong
because the other person is saying well
okay i get it you're out of your mind
let's abide by the rules and see if we
can
uh come to some mutual agreement so
that's the right so that's why the right
gets accused of everything
so so how do you think we shift that
paradigm i'm sure you've heard the
phrase the breitbart phrase that
politics is downstream from culture the
the right obviously lost culture over a
certain amount of decades i think it i
think that actually is shifting right
now a little bit at least but in terms
of art and everything else is there
something better that say right leaning
or conservative i mean you described
yourself before as an old-school liberal
i mean that that's what put me on the
map i was trying to save liberalism from
the left five years ago or or seven
years ago uh but for any of us that are
roughly freedom loving you just want
people to live and let live kind of
people what can we do culturally or
artistically
uh or through the type of work that you
do to to turn this thing around because
it's not going to be the political
leaders that turn it around obviously
we can't do anything because that's not
the purpose of art
art
is the conjunct the conjunction of
inspiration with uh an audience that the
artist has some inspiration and if the
inspiration is reducible to be kind to
black people hate white people or or uh
people dying of cancer deserve our
compassion that's not inspiration so
that's what art is art is art is a
very close it can of course leak into
religion and it's not at all uh
connected to politics
or culture
or it's it's like uh the oyster like the
oyster makes the pearl but the oyster
can't use the pearl
but other people can use the pearl but
the oyster can't the oyster is making
that pearl to influence people to dress
up their honey when they go out to the
nightclub
right the oyster has to make the pearl
it's going to go nuts
there's nothing that art can do what we
can do is speak the truth to each other
and be and not give in
not because it's the daily uh erosion
of life of i'm gonna tell you my five
pronouns or
would you like to you wait a second you
have to identify yourself or are you
vaccinated this constant shepherding
each other day to day which is killing
and to be able to deal with this retail
is exhausting it has to be dealt with
wholesale and the way you deal the
individual deals with wholesale say
thanks i'm not playing i'm not playing
that game
you know it's like what we learned from
you know i learned anyway from you know
gay friends gay liberation 30 years ago
40 years ago we're here where queer get
used to it
right
it's not my problem that i'm gay right
if you've got a problem with that that's
your problem
so that's what we have to do we have to
speak up and say you know and in fact
we're here we'll clear get used to it
because then it starts to crumble a
little bit
when that look on people's face you know
that you've seen it where they say oh my
god he's not he's not playing my game
that actually uh gets nicely to a phrase
that's in the book that i really loved
you talk about a virus
of conformity and and that seems to be
it almost more than anything else that
the media the politicians the people
you know covid vaxxes
gender pronouns the whole thing that
everyone is in on a bunch of stuff that
nobody really believes
that's true
but as shakespeare another jew said
truths a [ __ ] that must be whipped to
kennel while lady the brock can sit by
the fire and stink ladies abroad means a
female dunk
truth's always a [ __ ] that must be
whipped to kennel if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell